I'm her team's navy grandson.
google launches and in today's episode
Let's understand how it works like this.
you have and understand them good filters
three of the main components of a
application
the activities of the service body care
accessible they are activated through
messages that we then arrived from
do not even try on themselves or
an object understands is an attitude given
passive and which deals with the description of a
intention of something to be done by
this is understood from the blog of cash
and civil matters of something that ended
happening is being announced by the
coc system good and how we go
to ensure that these understand the
correct components there are three
different ways to be delivered
one understands
the first is that you call 1 with 3
start activity points are happening in
if a new tivit or if it already has
started but is coming back for something
new or even through the
points 7 revolt that when
You go along, you and I.
example citing is an understand
representing the information that is
wants to go through that other tite too
can be sent by a service through
the streets ways to be so service
either by start service or by the
hedges and last but not least
important
we have good ones that you can afford
pass someone try for any even
that broadcast them and with that the
intendants will then be handed over to
who is interested in hiring
that good broadcast an object of
understanding is basically a set of
do not talk about it.
intention and it contains the information of
interest of the components that receive
this understands and also the android system
as a woman then what are these
components there
the first is the name of the component that
represents who will treat this understanding
it is composed the full name of the class
you will receive in the clear case using pac
ottey me class name remembering that the
package name has the same name as the
package you registered for your
application
It's okay after that we have action that
It is properly said that you want
we do, then we have some
actions defined in a constant can
see the list of documentation to view
what conditions are available or what
you can take a specific action from your
application from your library that you
also defined ok
the data in this case is a url and also
online type of where the information is
What do you want, the one that understands the bridge?
so for example you want to send a photo
for an application to handle this does not
will you put the photo file by
example mytype referencing an image
OK
then we have the category of this
It's cool that you can take
any number of categories step
understand why you will give a
subdivision of what kind of reaction
will perform an action to the
edition category is new and is
save something then you can
organize your intentions well touch
we also have the extras part that is the
key parent and value course
where you will put information
really extras for those who are treating
of yours then in the freeport case the
istream car or any object that
Do you want to pass on to the next one?
component that will treat your understanding
and lastly we have the flex is that
will work as if it were instructions
for the android system to know how
is to launch, for example, tivit or
musician to deal with after she's gone
launched
the folds so they are defined in the
class intent and worth giving a
documentation so that you know which
you can use in your app
touch and how we are then know
that one understands and will be delivered by
correct component
good we have is a division of two
groups understand that this is to end
How are they going to be delivered?
the first are the explicit ones they
set the component name is
directly in what he already said was
previously understood in this way it is
I already know
to whom she goes independently she understands
filter something so it goes straight
with that component that give you the name
ok
after that it has the implicit ones ie
where I do not have a companion name
defined in this case is going to have a
change a little bit in the way how the
to choose who will treat is understood
is the content of the object then in the case
understands is tested compared to some
filters that we call understand
filter is good and how does it work?
understands them identified filters
it is to inform the system which
intents a certain component is tivit
about what you think you can see
and each component may have
more than one type of filter has no
has limits and will define what type
to identify you will treat there
good cause of simple to intendant
will be delivered to whom problems
coincides with one of the criteria of the
intendente filter touch and in the case of
explicit cells are not even tested
is consistent filters because if you already
put the component goes straight pro
component does not have to be tested
with identified having good
The tests I am telling you are
based on what is good for the nation thing I
I have to know who will do that.
central has a good filter point
action or by a category in which the
that I can tie an action and also
divided by category and also clear by
type of data information that is
transferred together with that
and the flag and extra information is not
are considered at the time of testing the
Try to filter a glance
Quickly to close some of us.
examples
first you're seeing there it's how
I move from one asset to another and
in this case I'm passing a string and
an extra object
I create understands passing the context that
the current class and then any kind of
destination adds 30 more method I could
stream add an extra with a putt
extra and call start it happening
understands with an easy parameter in this way
You started a new tivit by going
this new good object also for example
here people where we were creating
an application he has information
care so in the case and will treat data
of the image type
he can handle the display do what he
it defines better and in this other example
here then I now have the schema type
of the data in this case has a gold scheme
http and also the video type then what
this is an application that can
receive a video via the internet and
this video in your good app then
with this, that is, they can understand
best how the intense ones work to use
the intensive use of your applications
for you to better handle events that
happens in the application on the system
android and so the app stay still
better in the next episodes
let's see what we will see how to use
still in a more professional way
these intense and open the application a
Thank you very much and until the
next